you'll ruin your life somehow some way
it is everywhere everywhere it can pass
into all the cells and tissues of your
body it was a very Progressive decline
in my aspirations alcohol is no lives in
our society you want to figure out
something that you're doing with your
life that's worth not getting drunk and
screwing up I Drank In Search Of
Happiness and in search of a lifestyle
that I thought would bring me to
happiness it didn't and I woke up one
morning going wow I've drank a lot but
I'm still not happy what's that about I
recall in high school the motivational
speakers will come to my school and say
don't do drugs but absent from those
talks with any reference to alcohol
alcohol got introduced to my life you
might say well why do people drink too
much it's like if you like alcohol
that's a stupid question it is ingrained
it's the social glue that sticks
everything together
foreign